impfen für alle zumindest theoretisch ab
siebten juni soll laut bundesregierung
die priorisierung komplett fallen dann
sollen sich alle impfen lassen können
wenn es denn genug impfstoff gebe
internationale appelle ungehört wieder
sterben menschen bei den kämpfen
zwischen israels armee und militanten
palästinensern und rücktritt nach
nazi-vergleich fritz keller tritt nach
nur 20 monaten als dfb-präsident ab
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers den hallen und
willkommen in einer neuen woche geben
sie uns 20 minuten für den
nachrichtenüberblick katja stresow hat
nachher den sport wer ganz im zeichen
des fußballs steht schön guten abend das
war es wohl mit der priorisierung beim
impfen in deutschland ab siebter juni
sollen sich alle über 16 jahre anmelden
können
auch wenn es dann noch nicht genug
impfstoff geben dürfte so hat sich der
bundesgesundheitsminister mit seinen
länder-kollegen heute geeinigt wie er
sagt wir sind übereingekommen am 17 juni
in drei wochen die priorisierung
aufzuheben das gilt für die arztpraxen
das gilt für die betriebsärztin und
ärzte und die impfzentren gleichermaßen
die entscheidung einzelner länder ins
bett auch bei den arztpraxen und im
betriebs ärztinnen ärzten in den
modellprojekten frühzeitig und
frühzeitiger die priorisierung
aufzuheben die bleibt davon unbenommen
jens spahn der bundesgesundheitsminister
es bleibt jetzt eine reihe von fragen
zunächst einmal das ist nicht genug
impfstoffe dafür alle und dann stark und
allah banerjee guten abend welche
reihenfolge entscheidet denn dann ohne
priorisierung gilt dann zukünftig wer
zuerst kommt wird zuerst geimpft
also im prinzip ja so sieht dass dieser
beschluss ja im allgemeinen vor aber man
muss auch dazu sagen dass extra drin
steht dass das ganze eine skizze für
nächste wichtige schritte ist also im
prinzip nur eine eine grundlagen
einigung und in der praxis bedeutet das
jetzt nicht dass jeder der sich dann ab
dem siebten juni anmeldet auch sofort
geimpft werden wird also zum beispiel
bei den betriebs ärztinnen und ärzten
steht explizit mit drin dass da am
anfang noch geringe mengen impfstoff
vorhanden sein werden und dass ich das
erst mit der zeit steigern wird
also da ist noch nicht ganz klar ob das
ganze dann auch wirklich flächendeckend
in der gleichen geschwindigkeit voran
gehen kann und dann ist das impfen
ländersache und den ländern scheint auch
jetzt offenbar so eine art hintertür zu
bleiben besteht ein schlag unter die
chance dass es dann nicht
bundeseinheitlich laufen wird ab 17 juni
ja dafür muss man wohl ausgehen wir
haben aus der runde der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz tatsächlich
gehört dass nicht alle länder gleich
begeistert gewesen sind
von diesem vorschlag man will zwar in
dieselbe richtung ziehen und damit auch
ein zeichen setzen dass man natürlich
das impf tempo weiter erhöhen möchte und
möglichst vielen menschen ein
impfangebot machen will aber der
beschluss ist so weit gefasst dass für
jeden amateur unterm strich etwas dabei
ist die länder die sich schon dazu in
der lage führen die können also ab dem
die können schon vor dem siebten juni
die priorisierung aufgeben da gibt es ja
jetzt schon bundesländer und länder die
das skeptischer sehen die haben die
möglichkeit weiter zu priorisieren auf
länder ebene kommunaler ebene oder sogar
in den einzelnen arztpraxen
also das ist ebenso offen gefasst dass
sich alle irgendwie dran halten können
so lange sie den geist des ganzen
insgesamt insgesamt tatsächlich
akzeptieren
ok vielen dank und aller du hast gerade
schon angesprochen kommt man jetzt auf
die aktuelle lage beim kämpfen da ist im
moment eine runde zahl erreicht stand
jetzt wurden in deutschland mehr als 40
millionen impfdosen verabreicht der
großteil in den impfzentren gut zehn
millionen in arztpraxen
insgesamt sind damit rund 37 prozent der
deutschen mindestens einmal geimpft ab
siebten juni haben wir ja gerade gehört
soll es überhaupt keine priorisierung
mehr geben ärztinnen und ärzte in
baden-württemberg und berlin haben schon
seit heute freie wahl
bayern zieht am donnerstag nach und
sachsen nächste woche alexander pohl
berichtet rechnet
der hausarzt oliver busch ii mit einem
regelrechten ansturm auf die arztpraxen
grundsätzlich halten wir die
entscheidung für richtig wir hätten uns
gefreut wenn wir noch ein bisschen mehr
zeit bekommen hätten der schritt kam
relativ plötzlich für uns im laufe der
woche können die ärzte unabhängig von
der impfverordnung selbst entscheiden
welche patienten zuerst geimpft werden
diese regelung gilt zunächst in drei
bundesländern so soll der vorhandene
impfstoff schneller in die arme der
menschen gelangen
vielerorts aber fehlen die benötigten
dosen man bestellt 30 biontech zb
kriegen wir momentan höchstens die
hälfte bei den menschen mischen sich in
die freudige erwartung auch kritische
töne
ich finde es gut weil dann kommen die
leute wieder in die reihe ich denke sie
noch nicht alle die wirklich
vorerkrankungen haben geimpft und da
finde ich schon schwierig schwierig
findet das auch die stiftung
patientenschutz sie fürchtet eine
spaltung der gesellschaft
er soll als erstes geschützt werden und
da sind es die berufsgruppen die
chronisch kranken und die alten lösen
wir das auf dann wird letztendlich die
gerechtigkeitsfrage geopfert dem
widerspricht der bayerische
gesundheitsminister und sagt für die
politik sei es schwierig es allen recht
zu machen
jetzt haben wir die chance jetzt tun wir
das und ich glaube ihm ein bisschen
gegenseitiger rücksichtnahme können wir
das auch gemeinsam schultern anders als
in den hausarztpraxen soll die
priorisierung in den impfzentren weiter
bestehen bleiben und hier jetzt die
aktuellen corona zahlen mit einer weiter
positiven tendenz die neuinfektionen
gehen weiter zurück
innerhalb von 24 stunden wurden 5412
neue fälle gezählt das sind 1500 zehn
weniger als vor einer woche
64 todesfälle kamen hinzu keine bewegung
bei der sieben tage incidents sie liegt
wie gestern bei 83,1 und jetzt in der
sendung unser nächstes großes thema
heute abend die kämpfe zwischen israels
armee und militanten palästinensern
gehen in die zweite woche
es gibt intensive internationale
bemühungen um eine waffenruhe
die bundeskanzlerin hat heute mit
israels premierminister telefoniert
die kämpfe gehen derweil weiter mit
unverminderter härte immer wieder
schießen militante palästinenser raketen
auf israelisches gebiet betroffen sind
vor allem die städte beerschewa
aschkelon und aschdod
die israelische armee flog dutzende
luftangriffe auf gaza nach angaben eines
militärsprechers ist ein tunnelsystem
bombardiert worden
es wird seit jahren von der hamas
benutzt um im gazastreifen kämpfer
munition und lebensmittel zu bewegen
auch mit fahrzeugen axel sturm hat die
details wir treffen svetlana thierhoff
soffin schutzbunker
der schock sitzt noch tief es war wie so
oft in den vergangenen tagen knapp hier
in rastatt 15 kilometer vom gazastreifen
entfernt es war ein lauter knall zu
hören alle waren unter schock ein junge
hat geweint und gesagt ich will nicht
sterben ich will nicht sterben ich habe
ihm gesagt dass wir nicht sterben werden
dass wir hier nicht in gefahr sind
es war sehr furchteinflößend zum glück
waren wir wir hätten auch in unserer
wohnung im zweiten stock sein können
manchmal haben wir es nicht geschafft
svetlana hofft auf und ihre kinder haben
überlebt dieses mal an diesem tag der
raketen terror der hamas geht weiter tag
die antwort des israelischen militärs
ebenso hinter den kulissen wird
verhandelt die usa russland ägypten
angeblich gespräche auf hochtouren
wir arbeiten intensiv und versuchen ein
ende dieses konfliktes herbeizuführen
präsident biden hat mit einem netanjahu
gesprochen und mit präsident abbas
allein es gibt keine anzeichen auf eine
waffenruhe
im gegenteil auch im westjordanland
gewalt zwischen palästinensischen
jugendlichen und israelischen
sicherheitskräften
die hamas hat erst am abend angekündigt
erneut raketen auf tel aviv abfeuern zu
wollen
beginn läuft nach tel aviv michael
bewerunge da eine waffenruhe
auf die warten ja viele unbeteiligte auf
beiden seiten wirklich sehnsüchtig sind
wir denn heute einen schritt näher
gekommen
vielleicht ein bisschen zumindest haben
die usa ihre stille diplomatie
aufgegeben und machen jetzt mehr druck
außenminister blinken hat öffentlich
alle parteien dazu aufgefordert die
gewalt sofort zu beenden
an wen richtet sich das vor allem an den
engen partner israel
denn die hamas hat die bereitschaft zu
einem waffenstillstand erkennen lassen
sie hat aber ihre kriegs ziele auch
erreicht sie hat die verwundbarkeit von
israel mit ihren raketenangriffen
losgelegt und sie hat erreicht dass die
palästinenser und auch viele arabische
israelis sich mit ihrem kurs der gewalt
solidarisieren
bei israelis hätte etwas schwieriger die
kriegsziele so zu definieren ganz
allgemein wird israel verhindern dass
die hamas möglichst bald wieder in der
lage ist raketen abzufeuern
sie will die infrastruktur zerstören
bloß wie definiert man dass da geht es
auch um die deutungshoheit wer ist am
ende der sieger in diesem konflikt auch
wenn es nur der gefühlte sieger ist die
verhandlung im hintergrund gehen weiter
ägypten hat sich eingeschaltet und
präsident sie hat gesagt ein
waffenstillstand sei in reichweite
aber bisher ist davon noch nichts zu
merken ich habe wohl alive aussteller
wie vielen dank denn nahostkonflikt ist
auch thema bei zdf heute live ab 20 uhr
30 sprechen die kollegen mit einem
palästinenser und ein israeli die sich
beide einsetzen für eine friedliche
lösung des nahost-konflikts und sie
können mitdiskutieren in der zdf- heute
ab und auf unseren social media kanälen
friedlich demonstrieren gegen das
vorgehen der einen oder eben der anderen
seite in diesem konflikt das haben am
wochenende tausende getan hier in
deutschland dazu kam aber auch aufrufe
zu gewalt und antisemitische hetze die
bundesregierung sagt heute
antisemitismus seien gift mit dem man wo
immer nötig mit den mitteln des
strafrechts aber vor allem auch mit
aufklärung und kontakten zwischen den
menschen begegnen müsse markus gross
hass und hetze gegen israel
antisemitismus auf berlins straßen
hunderte pro-palästinensische demo
teilnehmer riefen am samstag offen zur
gewalt auf bilder die um die welt gingen
die politik in deutschland ist alarmiert
ob es linken antisemitismus gibt oder
rechten antisemitismus oder
zugewanderten antisemitismus was auch
immer in deutschland wird dies nicht
geduldet antisemitismus menschenhass
sind nicht teil des demokratischen
diskurses klare worte auch von der
bundesregierung
solch eine einstellung ist in
deutschland inakzeptabel
das muss jeder wissen und es muss auch
jedem mit den mitteln des rechtsstaats
klar gemacht werden
julia kopf von der recherche stelle
antisemitismus registriert seit tagen
verstärkt judenfeindlichkeit vor allem
von anonymen nutzern im netz
das sind 1 beschimpfungen beleidigungen
aber auch bedrohung zum teil auch
morddrohungen die personen
judenfeindlichkeit und gewalt auf
deutschen straßen woher kommt der hass
unter jungen muslimen defizite in der
integrationspolitik nicht wenige
experten sehen das so wir haben wirklich
nicht da investiert wo wir investieren
sollten in unserem bildungssystem in
unserer integrationskurse
integrationskurse reicht nicht irgendwie
mülltrennung zu vermitteln sprache zu
vermitteln sondern dazu gehört auch
wertevermittlung zu diese werte gehört
auch dass antisemitismus in diesem land
nichts zu suchen hat auch der ruf nach
härteren strafen gegen antisemitische
gewalttäter wird jetzt laut die
polizeigewerkschaft fordert ein
gemeinsames vorgehen
wir müssen bei den sicherheitsbehörden
die kompetenzen bündeln
müssen all diejenigen die sich sowieso
mit antisemitismus befassen aus
unterschiedlichen blickwinkeln heraus
zusammen bringen weil wir hier eine neue
priorität benötigen das macht die
aktuelle lage total deutlich berlin will
am donnerstag erst einmal ein zeichen
setzen mit einer solidaritätskundgebung
für israel am brandenburger tor anderes
wichtiges thema jetzt der klimaschutz
und die frage wie wir uns künftig
fortbewegen hier in deutschland aber
auch in europa noch mehr bahn fahren
fordern da nicht nur umweltschützer
doch dass es vielen zu teuer und
weiterer kritikpunkt es fehlt immer noch
an schnellen direktverbindungen heute
haben experten und politiker genau
darüber gesprochen ob es auch konkrete
ergebnisse gab dazu jetzt hans jürgen
thiel schnellzüge die europäische
metropolen verbinden sind heutzutage
eine seltenheit geworden
dabei gab es sie bis 1987 noch unter dem
namen trans europa express kurz de
geht es nach dem bundesverkehrsminister
dann soll es auch aus klimaschutzgründen
jetzt eine neuauflage geben
ob von paris über berlin nach warschau
oder von barcelona über straßburg nach
berlin
es soll schnell direkt und ohne
umsteigen gehen
so setzen wir anreize in europäisch vom
flugzeug auf die bahn umzusteigen
vier transeuropäische linien könnten
schon bald auf bestehenden gleisen
eingerichtet werden weitere erst nach
netzausbau online schienen gipfel mit
eu-verkehrsministern zumindest eine
absichtserklärung unterschrieb man heute
das ziel europäischer taktverkehr doch
gerade deutschland ist verglichen mit
den nachbarländern schlusslicht beim
ausbau der transitstrecken hängt auch
bei digitaler zug steuerung hinterher
warnen experten
die richtung stimme schnell wird es aber
nicht geben woran es noch fehlt das ist
der neu und ausbau also all das was
erweiterung des netzes ist was neu hinzu
kommt das ist unterfinanziert aber wir
brauchen mehr schienen gleise um diesen
europa takt fahren zu können
und insofern sind noch etliche
hausaufgaben zu tun immerhin bei
nachtzügen klappt die
grenzüberschreitende kooperationen
bereits unter federführung österreichs
ist ein netz zwischen ostsee und italien
entstanden
das unter dem namen eurolite ausgebaut
werden soll
und jetzt noch mal zurück zu kronor mit
einem blick nach großbritannien da
freuen sich die menschen heute über
weitere lockerungen in weiten teilen des
landes dürfen pubs und restaurants auch
wieder drinnen aufmachen museen kinos
und theater eröffnen und auslandsreisen
sind wieder möglich die inzidenz ist
niedrig aber es wächst die sorge vor der
indischen corona variante die sich in
einigen regionen großbritanniens rasch
ausbreitet diana zimmermann der bisher
eiskalte frühling macht den heutigen tag
besonders schön die briten dürfen wieder
rein in ihrer pubs und restaurants
monatelang bangende gastronomen sind in
feierlaune
es ist unser erster tag ich konnte es
nicht erwarten ich bin so aufgeregt
casinos machen ihre türen auf sowie
museen und bowlingbahnen etwas getrübt
ist die freude allerdings schon denn die
ursprünglich aus indien stammende virus
variante verbreitet sich rasend schnell
in der jungen noch ungeimpften
bevölkerung an den hotspots wird
massenhaft geimpft und getestet experten
warnen die neue variante gefährde den
bisherigen im erfolg und der
gesundheitsminister hofft dass die
bürger nicht über die stränge schlagen
es ist immer noch sicherer draußen zu
essen wenn das wetter es erlaubt und was
das umarmen angeht ist das ziemlich
sicher wenn es doppelt geimpfte tun
ab 21 juni soll eigentlich alles wieder
sein wie früher
doch das will die regierung jetzt noch
nicht bestätigen immerhin ist reisen
erst mal kein vergehen mehr die briten
dürfen runter von ihren inseln mit
ausnahme von portugal und elf weiteren
ländern gelten allerdings strenge
quarantäne vorschriften bei der rückkehr
doch wer die sehnsucht kennt der lässt
sich nicht bremsen und will es sich gut
gehen lassen post corona buchen die
briten vor allem vier und fünf sterne
hotels
sie machen sie mal einer an wir lassen
sie jetzt klar wir sind beim sport und
der deutsche fußball bund muss sich
schon wieder muss man sagen neuen
suchen oder eine neue präsidentin
vielleicht zum beispiel letzte woche
wurde es angekündigt heute dann
vollzogen
fritz keller ist als dfb präsident
zurückgetreten und zieht damit die
konsequenzen aus seiner verbalen
entgleisung im april als er
vizepräsident rainer koch mit nazi
richter roland freisler verglichen hatte
es ist ein abgang mit scharfer kritik am
weltweit größten sportfachverband auf
der dfb internetseite ist fritz keller
stellungnahme zu lesen
seine amtszeit sei geprägt gewesen von
einem anhaltenden machtkampf der
zerstrittenen verbandsführung die
durchsetzung eines programms und meines
auftrags durch den dfb bundestag wurde
mir an vielen stellen immer wieder
schwer bis unmöglich gemacht
der dfb muss sich verändern er muss
seine glaubwürdigkeit das vertrauen in
seine integrität und leistungsstärke
zurück gewinnen
übergangsweise wird der kriselnde
verband nun von den beiden vize
präsidenten peter peters links und
rainer koch geführt der dreizehnte dfb
präsident fritz keller war nicht mal
zwei jahre im amt wären nachfolger oder
nachfolgerin wird ist noch völlig offen
übermorgen wird der dfb den kader für
die fußball em bekanntgeben einnahme
wird dabei aber fehlen die nummer zwei
im tor marc andré ter stegen muss sich
am donnerstag am knie operieren lassen
und verpasst dadurch die nationalspieler
toni kroos muss wo ich später in die em
vorbereitung einsteigen wie vor wenigen
minuten bekannt wurde hat sich gross mit
dem kroner virus infiziert und fällt
damit auch bei seinem verein real madrid
im kampf um die spanische meisterschaft
aus im champions league finale der
frauen erwischten die deutschen
nationalspielerinnen melanie leupolz und
torhüterin ann katrin berger einen
schwarzen tag die verloren mit dem fc
chelsea 0 zu 4 gegen den fc barcelona
melanie leupolz kehrt dem finale schon
zur pause den rücken zu ausgewechselt
noch keine minute ist gespielt da wird
die ehemalige münchnerin kurz nach einem
lattentreffer barcelonas von einer
eigenen mitspielerin angeschossen
hier und in hohem bogen landet der ball
im tor
die deutsche schiedsrichterin riem
hussein ahndet elf minuten später ein
foul von laubholz strafstoß barcelona
das 2 0 entstand 14 uhr barcelonas
frauen erstmals champions-league-sieger
und freiwillig unterstützt von melanie
leupolz danach sagt ein bitterer abend
aber sie stolz wie weit sie gekommen
sind
danke katja metz kunst gehört ja zum
geburtstag singen ja meist die anderen
diesmal lassen wir lieber den jubilar
selbst singen
[Musik]
75 jahre udo lindenberg der mann der
deutschsprachige popmusik quasi erfunden
hat sondern im halben jahrhundert prägen
seine lieder generation auf generation
seit jahrzehnten wohnt er in einem
hamburger nobelhotel eine lebende
legende zu der us film und musical gibt
und dies mehr als 1000 mal in die charts
geschafft hat
[Musik]
glückwunsch udo lindenberg zum 75 das
wetter schauer gewitter sonnenschein
wind diese vier begleiten uns durch
diese woche details gleich von katja
horneffer empfehlen das heute journal
mit der kollegin marietta slomka heute
um 20 uhr 11 morgen sind wir wieder hier
für sie da für heute danke und jetzt
hinein erstmal ein angenehmer
[Musik]
er nahm meine damen und herren nach 33
jahren ist das beste was uns passieren
kann richtig viel regen und auch heute
hatte es wieder kräftige regenschauer
zum teil auch gewitter gegeben
diesen kleinen tief dass da von den
niederlanden weiter nach osten gezwungen
ist diese regenschauer und gewitter
fallen jetzt am abend und in der nacht
mehr oder weniger in sich zusammen
die pause ist allerdings nur von kurzer
dauer denn schon morgen früh beginnt es
hier von südwesten wieder zu regnen und
vorher sind noch einige schauer
unterwegs die temperaturen in dieser
nacht sinken am oberrhein 18 grad und am
alpenrand auf 5 grad und liegen morgen
in den östlichen mittelgebirgen kaum
über 12 grad am alpenrand sind es elf
grad milder wird es dagegen hier in
magdeburg berlin oder dresden mit bis zu
17 grad und auch morgen gibt es wieder
jede menge regenschauer vielleicht gibt
es einen streifen wo sie häufiger mal
die sonne sehen können zwischen dem
erzgebirge und der nordseeküste aber am
nachmittag müssen sie auch dort mit
schauern oder kurzen gewittern rechnen
das ganze bei einem recht böigen wind
meist aus westlichen richtungen
und ganz ähnlich geht es dann auch in
den nächsten tagen weiter
mal zeigt sich die sonne meer im norden
mal mehr im nordwesten mal im osten und
das bei temperaturen am freitag von 13
bis 19 grad
guten abend